dicks you've probably heard of them but
did you know that one in one women gets
it at least a thousand dick pics on
social media every year it could happen
to someone you know the sky that I don't
even know send me a picture of his dick
and I was like yeah he's halfway up his
shelf but thanks to my new dick pic
Survival Guide you don't have to feel
like a victim today I'm going to talk
you through the steps of surviving an
encounter with an unsolicited dick pic
which is usually blurry and has poor
lighting and it's really out of focus
because [ __ ] photography which is a
unique and interesting skill that
actually provides a talking point that
may lead you to actually picking up
women
like literally is actual dick I'm
[ __ ] your hair growing out of it step
one start saving all the pictures of
dicks that you receive in a folder step
2 order these jigs in accordance with
their sides literally 50% of his dick
how do I grow out of it step 3 the next
time that you receive a dick pic send
that person somebody else's dick back to
them if I were to receive a medium sized
dick on Instagram I would consult my
folder and find a slightly logic to send
back to that person to both humiliate
and emasculate them at the same time it
would people have hairy dicks like a
thing like if I comb in step 3 does
often result in complete outrage for
example here's a message that I received
in response to sending some guy a random
dick what the [ __ ] whose dick is that
you dumb [ __ ] I don't want to see no
dick stupid [ __ ] gross [ __ ] where
appropriate copy paste the message they
send you and send it back to them
because that's probably exactly what you
were thinking when you receive the
random dick in the first place
I'm going to be painful to shave dad are
you sure enough step 4 usually just
involves sitting back and laughing about
how you've managed to emasculate
humiliate and infuriates someone all in
one sitting without actually having to
source any material of your honor I
don't know if this will stop 15 year-old
boys from sending me pictures of their
gross unkempt dicks but I do think that
it means we're one step closer to
winning the wall
on dick pics he hasn't ever even wept
has anyone actually sent a dick pic I
like gotten like a vagina back like from
a complete stranger at that ever what